today's topic preach why what why is it
that you talk white all the time
what what the [ __ ] does that mean you
know like when you're communicating i
feel like you're basically trying to
appeal to the white masses by changing
your accent in the way that you speak
don't we all
no i don't no you don't but when you go
to
when you were in the army you were
talking to your sergeants the same way
you were talking to privates i'd be like
no sergeant you will be
you know stuff like that yeah yeah
i keep it 100 all the time that's it
that's it yeah so why do you talk white
though because i feel like that's
because i keep it 99 no i feel like
that's [ __ ] bro
you think that's all white
do something agree
sure i could but
people don't understand like they see
that's the thing they see they see i get
this comment when i speak in french
they see this
all this and they assume some [ __ ] right
you're like this you're like that the
same way they see you they assume some
[ __ ]
you know i mean why do you talk white
what the [ __ ] does that even mean
what does that mean
talking white what do we mean by that i
think we all know we just don't put a
definition on it i'm not really sure
do i really talk white i mean i see you
talk with black people when i see talk
of life people i feel like you talk
differently definitely yeah definitely i
coach with you absolutely yeah because
there was a time in my life where if i
didn't do that i get beat
that's it i get beaten i was home
if i got home and i was speaking like a
quebecer i'd get [ __ ] beat i'm
apparently taboos
sandwich
if i talk like that i get my ass whooped
because not prop that's not proper
french my parents sent me to a proper
french school for that why that's
another question that's another a whole
other
a whole lot of discussion right the
relationship with france and haiti
that's a whole other [ __ ] discussion
and if i would go to school and have
that haitian accent i'd get beat
as a matter of fact a lot of people in
the states a lot of my cousins in the
states they have what they call a
haitian day
if they so much
i remember when i was i was i was
walking i was in cambria heights i was
walking with my cousin chilling i was
speaking french with him and at some
point we were passing in front of our
house and he's like yo shut up
shut the [ __ ] up and i was like
that's rude and we passed in front
so i started i
didn't talk
and they said she said sorry about that
it's just that these people they don't
like french people
what he meant by the only french people
that's in cambria heights is haitian
haitians were not really
liked
like that and he lives there so if i
speak in french with him in his
neighborhood and you got some neighbors
that don't like haitian people
right i leave i go back to canada
everything is kosher but he still has to
leave
he stays there he lives there right so
code switching was a big thing it's
always a big thing it was a thing to
keep your job it was a thing to not get
beat to take a lot of
not not
not not to take space to you know so i
is it a is it a like a caribbean thing i
don't know if is it a
son of him immigrant thing
maybe probably whatever yeah i call
switch i definitely co-switch i do it
it's not something that i even think
about that's still me so why do i do it
force a habit force a habit it meant a
lot of [ __ ] trouble if you were not
talking the right way to different
people if you go to different parts of
of of la and you say cuz to a
[ __ ] it's a goddamn rap you have
to change your language or else it's a
rap
you don't call blood someone that you're
not supposed to call blood or else it's
a whole [ __ ] rap your life can end
right now there's some people that do it
to some degree
that's it you just want to go you just
you're just trying to mind your business
and not be not be in trouble you just
want to do you want to go through life
pay your bills not get in trouble and
sometimes you just gotta adapt yeah but
adapting
means that they win
is give shut the [ __ ] up shut up
right now i'm just trying not to get
beat all right
all your mumbo jumbo [ __ ] safe space
i don't give a [ __ ] about that i'm just
in survival mode okay i ain't about that
[ __ ] no you gotta stand up to your shut
the [ __ ] up that ain't your life
sometimes you gotta [ __ ]
go row with the punches you cannot fight
every [ __ ] fight nah i'm standing up
bruh at the end of the day i'm gonna be
tired i go home i get beat i go to
school i get beat i'm in the street i
get beat nah b
i don't want to live that life
i gotta [ __ ] choose i'm outnumbered
out here and that's why that's why i
grew up i was outnumbered so no
i chose to only get beat at home
because there were only two my mama my
dad
went to school it was gross [ __ ]
so that's what
you know it is what it is i hear that in
french oh that's how you speak that's me
that's how i speak
i change i change my language
when i'm with people it is what it is
it can lower people's guards and [ __ ]
and now i don't even think about it
anymore
that's just who i am it's funny how
people are gonna look at me and be like
he being fake while i'm being the
realest that i that i am how so
cause that's that's me
when you hear me change my accent like
that that is actually part of my history
that's part of [ __ ] that i've been going
through that i had to go through to lift
them this you know i mean to be here to
be mentally sane to pay my bills
that's that's actually history that's me
so while you think it's fake or whatever
it's still me
it's me
so it's like whatever
sure that's your that's your definition
of speaking even the term you speak
white sometimes i speak proper sometimes
whatever they say that i
they say that i wanna i wanna appeal to
white people is that what you hear
i just wanna be understood that's it
why do you have to change the way you
speak to be understood about white folks
i said what i said it's not just about
waffles
it's not just about rubble i check it
for bad folks too yeah it's not just
about white folk i just want to be
understood yeah even when you speak to
cubans even when i speak to cubans i
want to lower the gods i don't want to
get robbed i don't want to get i want to
get in on the good side you know i'm one
of y'all yeah cool all right cool that's
party now hold on wait that's mexican
but doesn't matter you understood what i
mean
let me ask you let me ask you go ahead
at what point does it go from you trying
to adapt into your ass looking
i'm not trying to get nothing from them
that's the thing
but you said no you said you're trying
to
i'm trying to that we're cool but i'm
not going to call you over i'm not
overdoing i'm not going to call it
beautiful i'm going to be you're not
going up to wire people and be like oh
good day master well good day dibbly
dude how you doing brother
yeah yeah it's not that yeah you know
stop dancing nah b it's not that i'm not
no i don't want nothing for you i just
want you to leave me alone
that's it how far and it's not a precise
line i think what is ass looking for
some person is going to be something
else for someone else but for me it's
not because i don't want nothing from
them i'm just like hey what's good i get
whenever i meet a [ __ ] no matter
where you from white black whatever
whatever whatever
that [ __ ] has 50 points of
course that's figured like this is for
you to understand it's not
and
that's everybody got their chance to
[ __ ] up here you got 50 points right
and whatever you do or don't do or
whatever i take away or i add points
okay and that's it
so they all start everybody starts with
hey what's up how you doing unless i
read some [ __ ] that's off
off the bat
other than that that's that yeah
i think it's two parts i think
rather than people getting mad at folks
for perceivingly talking wide or talking
black or just code switching too much i
think you'd ideally want to create a
society where people weren't judged so
heavily
for the accents that they bore
i think people wouldn't feel the need to
change any of their accents or to adapt
any situations if they didn't feel like
they received a tremendous amount of
negative stereotypes thrown their way
you know
um
i've told this story before but even
when i worked in telemarketing job we
used to call people
for
charities and things like that and i'd
call people and i'd be like um hi my
name is adam and they would hang up
right away and it wasn't until i changed
my name
to a more traditionally american normal
sounding name that people would stay on
the call so for me to even keep my job i
had to change my name you did that yeah
not a hundred
right so 98
98
so
so good
you have to understand like it becomes a
necessity when you want to kind of
move through the society and just be
regular you get what i'm saying like i'm
not trying to have eyes on me i'm not
trying to stand out
but by virtue sometimes just the way
that you are you stand out because
you're not like the norm
not that you're trying but you're just
not and it's like i don't want these
eyes on me so sometimes you start to
conform a little bit right
that's one part of it the other part of
it is also like
what does it mean to talk black or top
light
because the suburban experience of a
black individual is completely different
than the inner city right somebody who
actually grew up in the ghetto is going
to have a different experience than some
black dude who grew up in montana same
thing for white folks right there is no
traditional simple accent based off of
skin color
right
even if i go to the states i can go to a
bunch of spots right i can go to like a
a nigerian immigrant family who's been
there for what two decades
they're gonna have a completely
different accent than maybe somebody was
naturally born or laugh of of the
diaspora if you will right there is no
traditional accent so i think sometimes
when people like try to conform even to
what traditionally sounding black looks
like that's more inauthentic in a way
than you sounding like whatever it is
the because most of the time our accents
are based off of the cultural influences
that we have and the environment that we
live in but it's not like we're all
monolithic we don't all grow up in the
same environments right some of us grew
up in more affluent neighborhoods some
of us grew up in poor neighborhoods
right and all those things will impact
the way that you sound
it's not a matter of just skin color so
that's why i cringe a little bit when i
hear people like man you're talking
white you're talking black it's like
bruh
you would think it was weird if i grew
up in a community community gated
community and i'm walking out here
talking about yeah cuz you already know
what time it is we out here shooting
from behind the clock
yeah yeah tell the delivery driver to
punch in the code [ __ ]
you know what i mean that sounds stupid
and there's a lot of rappers who do that
there's a lot of rappers there's rappers
who like never spent a day in the hood
their whole life and they're rapping
about guns and throwing up hoes and
pimping and [ __ ] it's not real but it
sounds black so i thought i think we
need to even get rid of those
stereotypes in a lot of ways because
it's not real it's not it's not real
reflection of our all experience right
so yeah i think it's more than anything
it's more limiting than anything to me
it's just someone that likes someone
someone does that and like i just i'm
like okay you haven't traveled yeah you
haven't traveled
you stayed in your little hood and your
perception of what black is in your
little hood that's what it is all right
cool
um
that's
black to you
that's your perception of what black is
to you but you haven't seen the world
there's different things yeah like okay
your perception of black is just one
thing
that can only be one thing it's funny
how you want to get out of you want to
get out
of the stereotypes
but you're reading but you create more
stereotypes what you're mad when they do
it but you enforce it on one side and be
like yo that's black that's black when
that motherfucker's like yo that's black
that's like you're like what the [ __ ]
you say
that's you
that's you
that's something that you have to verify
with you yeah and also let's be clear
white folks code switch we all code
switch whether whether it be with family
members we don't talk the way to our
elders that we do our younger siblings
we all have to adjust to certain
situations so just understand that's
part of the game
it's part of the game for everybody so
just remember that and like i said
before the idea is not that people have
to
uh speak one way all the time no matter
what is that we have a society where we
don't judge people for speaking however
they choose to
um well that's pretty much all i've got
anything else no that's pretty much it
buddy but bud